the U.S is warning that Russia wants to
Annex large parts of eastern Ukraine a
senior official said the U.S believes
Moscow is planning Sham referendums in
the Donetsk and luhansk regions
meanwhile Ukrainian fighters in the as
of style steel Works in Mario Paul say
Russian forces have resumed their
assault after a brief ceasefire allowed
for some evacuations elsewhere in
Ukraine both military targets and
civilians are coming under Fire
a Ukrainian rocket making quick work of
a Russian Patrol boat in the Black Sea
rockets and shells continue to rain down
on Targets on both sides of the conflict
here in Lehman in the dinette's region
civilians are once again among the dead
and injured
as their homes are caught in the
crossfire
unfortunately there are losses among the
civilian population
as of now we know of two deaths due to
the shelling
foreign
kilometers away in Maria pool there has
been some relief for the people in
trench in the asoval still works
according to the Russian military 126
people were able to flee during a low in
the fighting
buses operated by the Red Cross and
private Vehicles took them to safety
initial reports indicate around half
chose to go to russian-controlled
territory with the rest seeking safety
in ukrainian-held areas
meanwhile American diplomats have
returned to Ukraine they've set up
operations in Lev and have a strong
message for Russian President Vladimir
Putin
I would say the message to Russia is you
failed uh Ukraine is still standing the
government is still functioning and
we're going back to La Vie first and
then Kiev to help the government
we'll join the Hungarian and danish
colleagues who have already resumed
their diplomatic missions in the
Ukrainian capital
DW's funny fat Shah is in Keith and she
told me about the conditions the
hundreds of people still trapped inside
the as of store steel works are having
to bear
desperate and devastating if you listen
to what the deputy commander of the as
of regiment said yesterday that they're
trying to actually get to civilians
inside you have to imagine this is like
a Labyrinth of bunkers there was immense
shelling for the past weeks around that
steel plant as a result some people
can't even get to the entrance let alone
exit that place and even if they do the
shelling has resumed shortly after this
first group of people managed to leave
on a Monday which was really
unprecedented if you look at the fact
that already there were so many attempts
trying to rescue people out of this
heavily bombarded city of maripol and
how difficult this is within this
context the situation is becoming dire
by the hour not just by the day but
really by the hour access to clean water
access to actually oxygen all of this is
really making the situation for the
civilians in there and also the wounded
soldiers in there very difficult and
inhumane now about half of the people
who have been evacuated have decided to
go to russian-controlled territory do we
know why that is
it's a good question whether they really
wanted to go to Russian territory
whether they were forcibly removed just
like I uh we have seen happening
unfortunately along the course of this
war that tens of thousands of people
according to Ukrainian information have
been forcibly removed from these
occupied territories or partially
occupied territories by Russia we do not
know exactly whether these people really
left to russian-controlled territory
because they wanted to or because they
didn't see any other option as they were
trying to leave their Agony from inside
the steel plant or other parts of
maripole as a result we can't really say
that this happened as a fact what we do
know that one part of uh the the group
of people that could be evacuated went
towards separija which is a neighboring
region to Mario Paul which is Ukrainian
controlled and others went on towards
Russian control territories
DW correspondent Fannie fachar reporting
from Kiev thanks for that update
and we can bring in Ruth Diamond now
she's a senior lecturer at the
department of War studies at King's
College London Dr Diamond welcome to DW
thanks for joining us the US's warning
we've heard that Russia plans to hold
Sham referendums in order to Annex
Donetsk and luhans later Kirsten does
this suggest would you say that Russia
is about to do what it did back in 2014
when it annexed Crimea
well I think it suggests it's going to
attempt to do that but of course the the
fundamental difference is that when
Russia uh instigated the Sham referendum
in Crimea it was actually in control of
Crimea and um Russia is not having this
success on the battlefield in eastern
Ukraine as it wants so it's it's going
to attempt if it does attempt to do this
uh to our next territory but it doesn't
actually properly control now Russia is
saying um that about 1 million people
have been brought from Ukraine to Russia
since the War Began what evidence do we
have to suggest that these were forced
evacuations
I mean of course it's very hard to to
say anything for certain
um give firstly it's always very
difficult during conflict to say uh
things with a high degree of certainty
and and of course then also we don't
actually have access to uh the people
concerned but all the evidence seems to
be that these are forced displacements
uh into filtration camps inside Russia
and of course that is a war crime or
indeed a crime against humanity so
um whatever the Russian government is
saying about the displacement of these
people I think
um you know there's no evidence that any
of this is voluntary and indeed it's
it's simply another of Russia's crimes
against the Ukrainian people
and the line in Russia about these
evacuations what the Russian people are
hearing is that these people all came
willingly
so that's right and of course that's
precisely what you would expect the
Russian government to say is part of
their narrative but
um you know I don't think we should take
that any more seriously than any of the
other Russian claims about what's
happening in this war
now the EU is preparing a new wave of
sanctions including an embargo of
Russian oil how do you think that is
going to be received in Moscow
I think it's going to be received
extremely badly if it does go ahead
um you know clearly the Russian
government is very very heavily
dependent on energy revenues
and it clearly needs uh to continue to
receive energy revenues to carry on
Prosecuting this war
um so so I think you know further
sanctions particularly ones that really
clamp down on uh Russian oil exports for
example
um will go down very very badly in
Moscow
all right Ruth Diamond Russia analyst
from King's College London thanks so
much for your time
a European Union energy ministers have
been meeting in Brussels to discuss a
ban on Russian oil imports in a major
policy turnaround Germany says it will
no longer oppose an immediate ban on
Russian oil energy Minister abubat
Harback says Germany could withstand
such a move and has already reduced its
dependence on Russian energy supplies EU
ministers are also discussing ways to
prepare for a possible total Russian gas
shutdown over moscow's demands for
payments to be made in Rubles Poland and
Bulgaria have already been cut off after
refusing moscow's demands
DW's Terry Schultz is in Brussels she
has more on whether they use ban on
Russian oil could go ahead
well it certainly helps that Germany
will no longer block that move but again
you've got Hungary and Slovakia saying
they don't want to follow that line it's
expected that EU ambassadors will begin
discussing a draft of the six-package of
sanctions that would include a ban on
Russian oil this week and that
commission Chief Ursula vanderland could
announce this six package later this
week but it may be that Hungary and
Slovakia could be given some kind of
exemptions in order to get that package
passed
Israel has summoned the Russian
Ambassador and demanded an apology after
Russia's foreign minister claimed Nazi
leader Adolf Hitler was part Jewish Sega
lavrov made the comments when speaking
about Ukraine's President Vladimir
zielinski who is Jewish solensky accused
Russia of forgetting the lessons of the
second World War
he interviewed on Italian television
Sergey lavrov is challenged on Russia's
claim to be fighting Nazis in Ukraine
president zelenski puts forward an
argument saying what kind of
natification can we have if I'm a Jew if
I remember it right I may be wrong
Hitler also had Jewish Origins so it
doesn't mean anything at all for some
time we have heard from the wise Jewish
people that the biggest anti-semites
were Jewish
lavrov's words of course outrage in
Israel which has so far avoided strong
condemnation of Russia's invasion
it's an unforgivable scandalous
statement as you said and also of course
a terrible historical mistake and we
expect an apology the Jews didn't kill
themselves in the Holocaust my
grandfather wasn't killed by Jews my
grandfather was killed by the Nazis to
say that Hitler was of Jewish origin is
like saying the Jews killed themselves
in the Holocaust
at Israel's Yad vashim Holocaust
Memorial there was also condemnation at
Russia's allegations of Nazism in
Ukraine to justify its War
Distortion also its use of Nazi
terminology regarding the Ukrainian
government and president zelenski
particularly is also a denigration of
the term is an offense and a front to
the victims of the real Nazism
historians say speculation about
Hitler's ancestry is based on a debunked
myth lavrov's use of the fallacy showed
Russia had no concern for the victims of
real Nazism says president zelensky
these words mean that Russia's top
Diplomat puts the blame on the Jewish
people for Nazi crimes I have no words
such an anti-semitic thrust by their
Minister means Russia has forgotten all
the lessons of World War II or maybe
they never studied those lessons
but Ukraine hasn't forgotten Russia's
attack on kiev's television Tower in the
opening days of the war the missiles
fell close to the babanyan memorial site
to Massacre Jews Holocaust Survivors
have condemned Russia's words and its
bombs